wir kommen nun zu unserem
tagesordnungspunkt 1 wahl der
bundeskanzlerin
der herr bundespräsident hat mir hierzu
mitgeteilt gemäß artikel 63 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland schlage ich dem deutschen
bundestag vor
frau dr angela merkel zur
bundeskanzlerin zu wählen
der demonstrative beifall ersetzt die
wahl nicht deswegen darf ich ihnen für
den anschließenden wahlgang noch einige
hinweise geben
zur wahl sind die stimmen der mehrheit
der mitglieder des bundestages das heißt
mindestens 316 stimmen erforderlich
nach unserer geschäftsordnung für die
bundeskanzlerin mit verdeckten
stimmzetteln also geheim gewählt
sie benötigen für diese wahl in ihren
war ihren wahlausweis aus ihren
stimmkarten fach in der lobby bitte
kontrollieren sie ob der wahlausweis
ihren namen trägt die stimmkarte und den
amtlichen wahlumschlag erhalten sie nach
aufruf ihres namens von den
schriftführerinnen und schriftführern an
den ausgabe tischen hier oben links und
rechts neben den wahlkabinen ich bitte
sie von ihren plätzen aus über die
seitlichen zugänge und nicht durch den
mittelgang zu den ausgabe tischen zu
gehen
wir haben das ja alles mehrfach
durchgeprobt es geht so am zügig stn
sie dürfen ihre stimmkarten uhr in der
wahlkabine ankreuzen und müssen die
stimmkarte ebenfalls noch in der
wahlkabine in den umschlag legen
danach gehen sie bitte zu den wahlurnen
hier vor dem rednerpult
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
sind verpflichtet jeden zurückzuweisen
der seine stimmkarte außerhalb der
wahlkabine kennzeichnet oder in den
umschlag legt gegebenenfalls kann die
stimmabgabe vorschriftsmäßig wiederholt
werden
gültig sind nur stimmkarten mit einem
kreuz bei ja nein oder enthalte mich
bevor sie die stimmkarten eine der wahl
ohne anwerfen übergeben sie bitte ihren
wahlausweis einem der schriftführerinnen
oder einem der schriftführer an der
wahlurne
der nachweis der teilnahme an der wahl
kann nur durch die abgabe eines wahl
ausweises erbracht werden ich bitte
jetzt die eingeteilten
schriftführerinnen und schriftführer die
vorgesehenen plätze einzunehmen
die beiden schriftführer neben mir
werden nun ihren namen in alphabetischer
reihenfolge aufrufen ich bitte sie den
namensaufruf zu verfolgen und sich nach
dem aufruf ihres namens zur
entgegennahme der stimmkarte zu den
ausgabe tischen vor den wahlkabinen zu
begeben
jan van aken einer weg man muss erst
fragen ob alle die schriftführer
eingenommen
umso ich habe den eindruck dass die
plätze mit den schriftführerin und
schriftführern besetzt sind das ist der
fall dann eröffne ich die wahl und bitte
mit dem namensaufruf zu beginn
es fehlt hier vorne noch eine
schriftführerin von den grünen
so wir hatten hier jetzt in dieser war
das liegt jetzt anders als vor vier
jahren etwas weniger geschmeidig ab sie
haben es gehört meine damen und herren
da wurden dynamischen aufgerufen obwohl
die bahn ob sie wirklich eröffnet über
die schriftführer und schlüpft foto
rente noch nicht eine wahl ohne standen
und das alles endlich eingeleitet haben
jetzt läuft es aber es werden bereits
stimmen abgegeben von stehen diese
beiden kleinen augen es fehlt hier vorne
im getriebe der komplett okay der
wahlgang ist eröffnet
es geht immer noch ein jahr in der tat
ein bisschen chaotisch geleitet
meine damen und herren ich gebe ihnen
das ergebnis der wahl bekannt abgegebene
stimmen 621 ungültige stimmen keine von
den abgegebenen 621 stimmen haben mit ja
gestimmt
mit nein gestimmt haben 150 mitglieder
des hauses neuen kolleginnen und
kollegen haben sich der stimme enthalten
gemäss artikel 63 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes ist die bis zur
bundeskanzlerin gewählt wer die stimmen
der mehrheit der mitglieder des
bundestages auf sich vereinigt ich
stelle fest dass vdr angela merkel mit
der erforderlichen mehrheit der stimmen
der mitglieder des bundestages zur
bundeskanzlerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewählt ist und auch wenn
ich aus der entgegennahme des
blumengebinde 's den begründeten
eindruck gewonnen habe dass sie sich
ernsthaft mit dem gedanken tragen die
wahl anzunehmen frage ich sie der guten
ordnung halber nehmen sie die wahl an
herr präsident ich nehme die wahl an und
bedanke mich für das vertrauen
langanhaltender stehender beifall und
sie haben zwei blumensträuße gab es
einen roten von der spd und eine in
deutschland farben gehaltenen von der
union also 462 jahr stimmen hatte
bundeskanzler fan bekommen die neue alte
die damit gewählt ist ändert ist sie
allerdings nicht mit ihrer amtszeit hat
wird auch erst beginnen sobald sie ihre
urkunde von mir auch im kopf der
bundespräsident hat es fehlen 42 stellen
das ist doch relativ viel ja wobei haben
dazu sagen muss
bei der ersten großen koalition unter
ihrer führung waren es 51 stimmen die
gefehlt haben bei einer kleineren
grundgesamtheit als dieses mal
also das ist glaube ich im bereich
dessen was sie was sie gut obwohl es
ganz sein ich darf ihnen im namen des
ganzen hauses herzlich zu ihrer wahl
gratulieren auch persönlich wünsche ich
ihnen kraft erfolg und gottes segen für
diese große aufgabe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
eidesleistung der bundeskanzlerin findet
um 12 uhr statt bis dahin unterbreche
ich die sitzung den bundespräsidenten
habe ich selbstverständlich vom ergebnis
des wahlganges unterrichtet die sitzung
unterbrochen